ぽっちゃご飯を食べるときど方も大抵本目んです答えてコンビニなんですけどメガーヌ
それでヒョンビンに耐えて売っているようなもの例えばおにぎりとビッグな原木が本免
でハマっているのがホットドック
エアー good reader free ビョークっ
喉の-0 b とアフターミー
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ今回こちらに有名な
コンビのホットドッグを5種類集めましたこの人たちは電子レンジがないんですよ
出兵し軍事がないので家に帰ってそこ温めて今帰ってきたところなんで
あ
ちょっと疲れてますまずはこちらもう王道といっても過言ではないでしょうセブン
イレブンのホットドッグついてこちらロートンのホットドッグですパリッとジューシー
なホットドックっていうことでちょっとパリパリッとしているのを売りにしてるのかな
としてこちらファミリーマートのホット取ってでさあこれはパリッとジューシーな送り
などはこれ家ベンはパリッとジューシーって書いてないんですけどもうそのパリッと
寿司って書いてあるんで
これは度はとローソンでパリッと[ __ ]シーバトルが行われる気がしますねそれこちら
ミニストップのホットドッグですね何か書いてあるかな
うまいことを交わしてますこれがちょっと微妙なんですけどもう山崎のホットドッグな
んですけどなかったんで
チーズのホット時になってしまいました今回の戦いでもチートなって自分で反則なんで
一応参考として一応チーズのフォトと組み入れておきますまあ小鶴ですねあのねほんと
でホットドッグってねうまいんですよちょっと解説させてくださいちょっともホット
ドッグでどこで生まれたかというとアメリカなんですまぁ簡単に言うとソーセージ
細いパンで挟んであるものをホットドックいますそしてアメリカにはなんとアメリカ
将棋が今それホットドッグソーセージ協議会というチームがありますてる人たちによる
とほっととかサンドイッチか全く別で大臣かホットドッグとシフトての食品であると
いうことが言われております味次はマスターたら基本でございますこの日にをずっとの
とケチャップをかけたり幅ネギをかけたり細かく刻んだピクルスを乗せられたりします
他にもチリミートをかけたチリドックと形だチーズをか
なものトマトなどの野菜を挟んだシカゴドッグたらさをかけたサルサドッグなど
さまざまなバリエーションがホットドッグにはありますさんならパンの食べ方の一種
じゃんって思う方もいると思うんですけどもけ集そういうわけではなくてまぁ歴史的な
しっかりとした食器の一つという認定化されておりますアメリカでホットドックが
生まれたと言いましたんですけどもキックスタートたどるとドイツの移民の稼働
本当に最近目指して食ってるんですよホットドッ今朝までホットドック好きになっ
たっていうとちょっと先肌寒くなってきたので肉まんとかあったなもの食べようかなと
思ったんですけどここはせっかくなホットドッグを食べてみようと思って買ってみたの
がきっかけで走者程食べてみるととっても美味しくて気づいたらほとんどこの鳥でも
早速1個ずつ開けてみましょうかねぇ早く食べないと冷めちゃうとか武利岳の話を先に
させていただきましょう
彼の例でいうと7の方はが197kcal ノーズが279kcal 餌三馬が
290kcal ミニストップの287kcal 山だけのチーズホットドックが
310月キロカロリーまあこれはチーズかかってる仕方ないですねローターのほ届けが
一番カロリーが低いですさあちょっとあの本当にあずあるコンビニの中でホットドッグ
を買うときにどう
これを買えば一番いいのかっていうのはとても気になるところなんですよ
個人的に月の本気でね正しく両道でしっかりと判断していきたいと思いますアメリカの
食い物なんて見た目なんてあんまり検知年だそう
ただ出なければいい俺達の心に響けソウルフードならそれでいいじゃん
いただきますうーんうまいんうまいん
今まはぁっ
moa
バーン
っていきたいところなんですけどもしっかり評価していきましょう今回は全然
ホットドッグ素人なんですけどもホットドッグのポイントを3点に絞りたいと思います
まずはパーンそして高のソーセージ後はマスタードケチャップ
まあソースですねこの3つでしょうかしていきたいと思いますちょっとごめんなさい
もうちょっと食べて強化させてください
[音楽]
お腹いっぱいになっちゃったやばい結構判断しようと思って食いまくったらお腹が
いっぱいになって言っちゃっだいたいな程度つけてみたのでちょっと順番に見ていき
ましょうマザー
77ズバリ言いましょうパンの定数3その政治が子ソースがさんってございましたあの
おいしいんですよ他のホットドッグの船名ネームのホットドッグ大菊ちゃうところが
いい
行ってあげましたそれは何かと言うとパンなんでしょホットドッグのパンのその総数
千春ティルの部分でちょびっと猫の記事が使っていまして他の絵って何か強いんです
けどもそんなに差がないんですけども7がもうがっちり違いますからねここは側って
違うんですけどもなんかそれのせいか知らないんですけどもパン時代がちょっと固くて
パサパサしてるんですよねわからないでしょうか本番
アメリカじゃないとわからないんですけどひょっとしたらアメリカだとアメリカだと
ですよアメリカだとファンのバーリはこのか探してで正解なのかもしれないこれが本番
のホットドッグここは日本です
僕個人的にはちょっとこのパサパサしたパンがあんまりウケなかったので3.2させて
いただきましためちゃ美味しいですでも
溶損もなあなあ彼方いい線いってると思うんですけども
panna 4転送フェーズが子って本数が3点ぐらいかなっていう感じですね
でソーセージもずうしかめと肉汁でちょっとドロー落ちてくるけどとても美味しい
いい
[音楽]
だだ
ソースがこういったやバカね俺個人の意見だからねマスタードがすごいなんか粗挽き
すぎるむしろなんか何このツブツブがメインみたいな状態になっててちょっと辛すぎる
かなっていう印象が僕の中にはあったんですけどみなさんはどうか分かりません僕は的
なので阿波東の芸の一つとしてちょっと
マスタードは潰れすぎて荒挽きすぎている感じ発音がおかしかったらあら
行き過ぎてる感じがしました
次
ファミリーマートですはいアメリーまあどのホットドッグズバリ
パン神戸政治山荘すっごいイメージです僕の中ではただぼれたぶんね俺だけな気がすん
じゃないものが好きな人が実はがすごいオススメな気がしますなんかこう日本対応させ
ている感じがすごい気がしますでソーセージ骨パリパリしてて美味しいんですけどもう
ちょっと細くて物足りないか
なってイメージが僕の中ではありましたソースが素晴らしいあらびきマスタードでは
なくあの子供たちが好きなあの普通の黄色いあのマスターと使っているのでちょっと
甘くて個人的にファミマの奴が一度食べやすいかなっていうかちょっと甘い感じで気軽
に食べれたかなって思います
4つ目はミニストップのホットドッグですいません公正な判断ができないかも知れませ
んあなたがいっぱいですか
うーん単四ソーセージ4ソース4なんかマジがは風がわからんけどプレイっつったら女
が空いていると聞いんだと応じそうだからそうでが美味しい
れちゃってシンプルなホットドッグです
じゃあ最後山崎のホットドック食べて行きたいと思いますいただきます
これは
ホットドッグではない量ができないホットドックでのフォト得で7鞍に
注い漕艇場挟んでん
ケチャップまずだろ
このコンビネーションで初めてホット撮ってんだだからこの傷が入ってるほどかホット
ドッグやんね
よって
失格
ben
まぁ今回食べてみて僕が一番おいしいと思ってホットドッグあ
[音楽]
米ダウお腹いっぱいでよくわかんねーなっ
me
バッハ
まあ個人的には
ファミマかなファミマが凄い美味しかったと思います個人的には
よかったら皆さんも食べてみてください